i love the animated version it's
thrilling to take some of the beloved
sequences
and make them happen in the real world
mulan brought a big dose of girl power
into our lives in the 1998 disney
animation
but will the live action version live up
to the hype we're spilling the tea on
what major changes we can expect
there are differences that we're totally
psyched for fierce female villain anyone
but there are also switches that we're
pouting over no mushu
no li shang wait what join us as we
dissect
every little and big difference
mulan's love interest lee shang is
missing from the live action movie
that's not to say the 2020 version is
without a romantic interest
but this time around the character is
called shen hong hui played by
yusun an and the really important
difference is that he's mulan's equal
not an authority figure he's mulan's
fellow recruit
and the ambitious soldier sees mulan as
his biggest competition
you're the best warrior amongst us
producer jason reed explained that in
the time of the hashtag metoo movement
having a commanding officer that is also
the love interest
was very uncomfortable they didn't think
it was appropriate
mulan and shen hong-whi don't get off to
a great start with him patronizing mulan
by calling her little
need a hand little man as for the
authority figure he's an entirely
separate character
donnie yen plays commander tongue it
seems you've been hiding something
the director says one of her favorite
moments was shooting his impressive
sword display in front of all the
recruits
in the animation lee shang had the
skills so
you'll die for honor mulan cutting off
her hair is one of the most iconic
scenes of the 1998 movie
but in the 2020 version mulan doesn't
chop her locks
she takes her father's sword but uses it
for fighting rather than hair styling
however both movies show mulan wearing
her hair up when pretending to be a man
in the training camp and she wears
uncomfortable restrictive clothing to
help with her look
so why did they cut that scene producer
jason reed admitted that mulan cutting
her hair is
is actually a western anachronism
chinese male warriors wore their hair
long
so ironically mulan's shorter hair would
have made her look like more of a woman
in the trailer we see lots of scenes of
mulan fighting with her hair down long
after her true identity has been
revealed i
knew there was something wrong with you
a woman
it's much longer than mulan's chopped
off hair in the animated movie
this changes once again to make the
live-action remake more faithful to
cultural traditions
my ancestors sent a little lizard to
help me it's not just li shang that
didn't make the cut in the live action
movie
one of the biggest changes from the
animated movie is the lack of mushu
the dragon voiced by eddie murphy
brought most of the comedy moments in
the 1998 movie
let's see your face oh i think my bunny
slippers just ran for cover come on
scare me girl
but the 2020 version is more serious and
more authentic
producer jason reed explained the dragon
is a sign of respect and it's a sign of
strength and power
and using it as a silly sidekick didn't
play very well with a traditional
chinese audience
although the director of the live-action
film nikki karo dished that mushu is
irreplaceable
eagle-eyed fans have spotted a potential
replacement for the protector role that
the dragon displays
and it's a phoenix mulan's father tells
her about
phoenix sits on the right hand of the
emperor she
is his guardian his protector and in
another trailer we see a phoenix appear
as mulan's father
asks ancestors please protect her
and that's not to say that dragons don't
appear at all in the 2020 film either
in the trailer we do see a dragon but
it's being held up with sticks as part
of what looks like a traditional dragon
dance
this is much more in keeping with
traditional representations of the
dragon
dragon drag gun not lizard i don't do
that tongue thing
this focus on a more traditional
representation of the dragon and
other aspects of chinese heritage is key
to this new version
stay tuned for more on that later their
leader calls himself
oricon sean yu is one of the most
terrifying villains in all the disney
animated features
but he's been replaced by a different
bad guy in the 2020 remake
this new enemy is bori khan and he looks
quite similar to sean yu
with a few subtle differences he has
heavy lined eyes but not yellow like the
1998 villain
bori khan has long hair but without sean
used bald patch on top
and bori has distinctive scars on his
face whereas shan yu has expressive
eyebrows
bori's the leader of the northern
invaders like sean yu whereas sean yu
was only motivated by power
it's personal for bori when we take the
imperial city i will take revenge for my
father
the director has spoken about how jason
scott lee nearly didn't make the cut
because he was a little round but their
trainer shredded jason in two months
with just organic food and exercise
and interestingly it's bori who gives us
a shirtless moment of muscles
that honor was given to li shang in the
1998 animation
we have two new characters our villains
rather than just one baddie we get two
in the remake
the second villain is called xi'an lange
played by gong li
and she's described as a witch her
makeup is fierce
it looks like she's a replacement for
sean use falcon her nails are like claws
and she can shape-shift into a falcon
her conversations with mulan shed light
on the view of women in the army
a woman in the man's army they will show
you
no mercy we also lose mulan's hilarious
grandmother in the live-action remake
however as we've seen
we don't just lose characters we gain
new ones too
and in the 2020 version mulan is no
longer an only child
she gets a sister played by zana tang i
am blessed with two daughters
we see mulan and her sister together
when the decree arrives instructing one
man from every family to fight
it's clear that mulan is older as she's
the one who's wearing makeup for the
matchmaker
we see mulan her sister and her parents
sitting around a table
this replaces the scene in the animation
when mulan and her parents are sitting
with her grandmother
we see mulan with her sister when their
mom tells them we must be strong
this new dynamic adds greater motivation
for mulan to serve in her father's place
as she has a younger sister to protect
too it is my duty
to protect my family this is more in
keeping with other more traditional
tellings of the legend as in some
versions mulan has a sister
and even a little brother the 1998 movie
got an oscar nomination for best
original score but the 2020 version
is stripping out all of the singing in
favor of an instrumental score
we get a snippet of the instrumental
version of reflection in one of the
trailers
the musical numbers are a big part of
disney animated movies
so why has the live action remake strip
them out it's all down to the desire to
make it more realistic
as the director points out we don't tend
to break into song when we go to war
she's keen to point out that she thinks
the songs are brilliant in the animation
christina aguilera has recorded a new
single for the film
called loyal brave true how do you think
that the new song stacks up against the
originals like reflection
i'll make a man out of you honor to us
all and a girl worth fighting for
the original ballad of mulan was written
in the 7th century and it's been
told countless times the cultural
background of the original legend
is a major driving force of the 2020
movie and that explains a lot of the
differences between this new film and
the 1998 animation
as executive producer bill kong points
out she represents many great great
great chinese values
these include honor good family loyalty
to the country
and that makes mulan an icon it was
clear to the actors that tradition was
of utmost importance
jason scott lee who plays bori khan
spoke about the importance of
authenticity
they're putting every ounce of effort to
get things right
that went across every aspect of the
movie and that also played a big part in
casting
especially when it came to the actor who
got the part of mulan liu yifei
the director explained we put her
through a grueling physical assessment
she's an accomplished martial artist
many people believe that mulan flopped
in china because audiences felt it was
too americanized and too removed from
the original legend
and that's why this version has so many
differences what do you think of the
changes in the live-action movie
we want to know what you think so be
sure to sound off in the comments
section
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love mulan as much as we do
thanks for watching
you